Nous pensons que les ordinateurs quantiques nous permettront de résoudre certains problèmes plus rapidement qu'avec des ordinateurs classiques seuls. Mais
comprendre comment est subtil. Aujourd'hui dans Qiskit en classe, nous allons essayer de découvrir la source de la puissance de
l'informatique quantique en examinant l'un des tout premiers
algorithmes. Bienvenue dans Qiskit en classe. Dans cette série, nous utiliserons Qiskit pour explorer quelques concepts fondamentaux
couramment abordés dans les cours liés à l'informatique quantique. Chaque vidéo est accompagnée d'un module interactif
lié dans la description ci-dessous. Alors, n'oublie pas de le consulter. Si tu as beaucoup entendu parler des ordinateurs quantiques, tu as
probablement entendu dire qu'ils peuvent utiliser des phénomènes quantiques comme la superposition, l'intrication et l'interférence pour résoudre
des problèmes d'une façon que les ordinateurs classiques ne peuvent pas. Mais comment exactement ces caractéristiques aident-elles ? En 1985, David Deutsch a été le
premier à montrer comment cela pouvait se produire. Il a imaginé ce qu'on appelle maintenant l'algorithme de Deutsch qui pouvait résoudre un
problème plus efficacement qu'un algorithme classique. Aujourd'hui, nous allons examiner l'algorithme de Deutsch et
une extension ultérieure appelée l'algorithme de Deutsch-Jozsa et examiner comment les aspects uniquement quantiques des qubits
peuvent être utilisés au profit des ordinateurs quantiques. Ensuite, nous exécuterons ces algorithmes sur un vrai ordinateur quantique avec Qiskit.
Il existe d'autres algorithmes quantiques qui montrent également un avantage théorique sur les algorithmes classiques connus. Et ils ne fonctionnent pas tous
selon les mêmes principes que ceux que nous verrons aujourd'hui. Donc ce que nous apprendrons aujourd'hui n'explique pas en général comment un ordinateur quantique
fonctionne, mais cela nous aide à commencer à voir comment les principes de la mécanique quantique peuvent être combinés pour
créer un puissant ordinateur quantique. Avant de plonger dans l'algorithme de Deutsch, réfléchissons d'abord à comment les ordinateurs quantiques
sont différents des ordinateurs classiques et comment cela pourrait nous donner un avantage pour résoudre certains
problèmes. Une différence est que les bits quantiques appelés qubits peuvent être dans des états de superposition. Au lieu d'être
limité soit à l'état zéro soit à l'état un comme un bit classique, un qubit
peut être dans un état de superposition de zéro et de un. Nous écrivons cet état comme
ceci où a et b sont des nombres complexes dont les carrés s'additionnent à un et plus il y a de
qubits, plus cet écart s'élargit. Deux bits ne peuvent encore être que dans l'un de ces
quatre états possibles. 0 0 1 1 0 ou 1
1. Deux qubits peuvent être dans une superposition des quatre états classiquement autorisés, ce qui est
écrit comme ceci. En général, un système classique de n bits ne peut jamais être que dans l'une des 2 puissance n combinaisons possibles
de zéros et de uns. Un système quantique de n qubits peut être dans une superposition de tous ces 2 puissance n
états. La mise à l'échelle est exponentielle. Donc même si nous n'avions que 10 qubits, ils
pourraient être dans un état de superposition de 2 puissance 10, soit 1 024 combinaisons possibles de zéros et de
uns. La mise à l'échelle exponentielle de l'espace d'états des qubits s'appelle le
parallélisme quantique et est en partie responsable de l'avantage des ordinateurs quantiques sur les ordinateurs classiques. Mais un ordinateur quantique
n'est pas qu'un processeur parallèle massif. Le fait que les qubits d'un ordinateur quantique puissent être dans une
superposition d'un nombre exponentiel d'états ne signifie pas que nous avons accès à toutes les informations dans chacun de ces
états. Puisque la mesure effondre le système dans un état ou un autre, voyons
comment cela se manifeste dans un problème simple. Supposons qu'il y ait une machine à laquelle
on peut donner un seul bit. Elle appliquera alors une certaine fonction au bit et en produira un autre. La machine
est à l'intérieur d'une boîte noire à laquelle nous ne pouvons pas accéder. Tout ce à quoi nous avons accès, c'est le bit
que nous lui donnons x et le bit que la boîte produit f
de x. Nous voulons savoir quelle est la fonction f que la machine applique.
Il y a quatre fonctions possibles qui prennent un seul bit vers un autre seul bit.
Donc pour savoir quelle est la fonction, on peut simplement lui donner un zéro et voir si elle produit un zéro ou un un, puis lui donner
un un et faire de même. Chacune de ces deux étapes s'appelle une requête. C'est
une façon de comparer les algorithmes classiques et quantiques via le modèle dit de requête où nous comparons le nombre
de requêtes que chacun des algorithmes doit faire à la boîte noire pour résoudre le problème. Donc dans ce cas, notre
méthode classique devait interroger la boîte deux fois pour apprendre la fonction. Voyons si nous pouvons faire mieux si nous avons un ordinateur quantique
qui interroge la boîte noire. Au lieu d'abord donner un zéro puis un un, l'
ordinateur quantique peut donner à la boîte un qubit qui est dans une superposition de zéro et de
un. Donc en fait, nous donnons à la boîte les deux entrées avec une seule requête. Alors
est-ce que cela signifie que nous pouvons apprendre la fonction avec une seule requête ?
Malheureusement, ce n'est pas le cas. Nous voyons pourquoi cette idée échoue lorsque nous la testons sur un ordinateur quantique. Nous allons créer un
circuit avec deux qubits. Le qubit zéro représenté ici par cette ligne du haut sera notre état d'entrée X que nous donnons au
circuit de la boîte noire montré ici par la gate bordeaux étiquetée UF. La gate UF est
conçue pour prendre un qubit zéro comme état d'entrée X puis appliquer une transformation sur le qubit un qui prend
l'état zéro vers l'état f de x. Donc tant que le qubit 1 a commencé dans l'état
zéro, la sortie est x sur le qubit 0 et f de x sur le qubit 1. Donc pour trouver f de x pour
x=0 et x=1 simultanément, nous pouvons essayer de mettre le qubit 0 dans une superposition de 0 et 1 avant
de le donner à la boîte noire. C'est fait avec cette gate Hadamard rouge qui transforme l'état zéro en 1 / 2
0 + 1. Donc après la gate de la boîte noire, nous devrions maintenant avoir une superposition des deux
f de 0 et f de 1 sur le qubit 1. Quand nous mesurons les deux qubits, nous espérons
répondre à la question : quelle fonction se trouve à l'intérieur de la boîte noire ? Utilisons le sampler primitif de Qiskit pour exécuter le
circuit et retourner le résultat. Nous pouvons choisir le nombre de fois que le circuit est exécuté, appelé échantillons, en modifiant ce
paramètre appelé shots ici.
WEBVTT
C'est équivalent au nombre de requêtes que nous faisons à la boîte noire. Voyons si une seule requête suffira.
Voici le résultat. Nous avons mesuré le qubit 0 à zéro. C'était donc la
valeur d'entrée x et le qubit 1 à 1, qui était la valeur de sortie f de x. Donc maintenant nous
savons que f de 0 est égal à 1. Mais qu'en est-il de f de 1 ? C'est là que le problème se pose. Une fois
que nous avons mesuré l'état, les superpositions se sont effondrées et nous n'avons pu mesurer qu'une partie de la fonction avec une
seule requête. Cela ne nous dit pas tout ce que nous devons savoir pour déterminer quelle fonction c'est. Nous aurions besoin d'une
deuxième requête à la boîte pour cela. Donc même si le principe du parallélisme quantique nous permet simultanément
de faire évaluer par la boîte noire f de 0 et f de 1, nous n'avons pas accès aux deux
réponses. Le parallélisme quantique seul ne suffit pas. L'algorithme de Deutsch
montre comment nous pouvons utiliser le parallélisme quantique un peu différemment pour apprendre quelque chose sur la fonction à l'intérieur de la boîte noire. Nous ne pourrons pas
apprendre exactement quelle est la fonction, mais nous pourrons apprendre quelque chose de nouveau à son sujet avec une
seule requête, ce que nous ne pourrions pas avec un ordinateur classique. Commençons par examiner un tableau des quatre fonctions possibles
qui prennent un seul bit vers un autre seul bit. Ici tu peux voir que deux des fonctions f_sub_1 et f_sub_4 retournent toujours
une seule valeur quelle que soit l'état d'entrée. Nous appelons ces deux fonctions
constantes. f_sub_2 et f_sub_3 retourneront soit zéro soit un selon
l'état de x. Nous appelons ces deux fonctions équilibrées. L'algorithme de Deutsch
détermine si la fonction est constante ou équilibrée en apportant quelques ajustements intelligents au circuit que nous avons utilisé
avant. Voici le circuit. Il commence par préparer le qubit 0 dans l'état 1 /
2 0 + 1 avec un Hadamard comme avant et le qubit 1 dans l'état 1 / 2 0 - 1
avec une gate NOT suivie d'un Hadamard.
Donc l'état complet à ce stade est là où voici l'état du qubit 0 et
voici l'état du qubit 1. Préparer le qubit 1 de cette façon plutôt que de simplement
le laisser dans l'état zéro permet à l'algorithme d'utiliser le parallélisme quantique en combinaison avec l'interférence pour apprendre
sur la fonction de la boîte noire. Voyons comment, quand les qubits sont introduits dans UF la gate de la boîte noire, quelques choses peuvent
se produire. Si la fonction est constante, alors la boîte noire effectuera une opération sur le qubit un seul, quelle que soit
l'état de zéro. Dans ce cas, puisque UF ne touche pas le qubit zéro ou
ne se soucie pas de son état du tout, alors le second Hadamard ici défait simplement ce que
le premier Hadamard a fait. Et nous mesurerons le qubit dans l'état zéro. Examinons la fonction équilibrée f_sub_2 comme exemple pour voir
ce que uf fait à l'état dans ce cas. Quand x est zéro, f de x est zéro et quand x
est 1, f de x est 1. Rappelle-toi ce que j'ai dit sur la gate uf. Elle prend le qubit 0
comme notre état d'entrée x et produit f de x sur le qubit 1. En supposant que le qubit 1
a commencé dans l'état zéro. Donc pour cette fonction, ce que UF fait au qubit 1 dépend
du qubit 0. Si 0 est zéro alors le qubit 1 sera laissé dans l'état zéro pour obtenir f
de x = 0. Si le qubit 0 est 1, la boîte noire appliquera une gate NOT au qubit 1 et le mettra
dans l'état un. Donc nous obtenons f de 1 égal à 1. C'est exactement ce que fait une gate NOT contrôlée ou gate C-NOT. Une
gate C-NOT prend deux qubits, un qubit de contrôle et un qubit cible, et inverse l'
état du qubit cible si le qubit de contrôle est dans l'état un. Mais elle ne fait rien à la cible si le qubit de contrôle
est dans l'état zéro. Donc UF pour F2 est juste un C-NOT sur Q0 et Q1. La gate C-
NOT ne fera rien au premier terme puisque le qubit de contrôle est dans l'état zéro. Mais sur le deuxième terme, ce
zéro se retourne en un et ce un se retourne en zéro. Et si on factorise un signe moins, on verra que l'état du qubit 1 est
inchangé. Mais ce terme a pris un signe moins. Donc l'état du qubit 0 est
en réalité celui qui a changé. Il est passé de 0 + 1 à 0 moins
un. Quand nous appliquons le Hadamard final au qubit 0, cela le transforme dans l'état 1. Donc si la fonction dans la boîte noire
est f_sub_2, nous mesurerons un au lieu de zéro. Il s'avère que la gate UF pour l'autre fonction équilibrée f3 est la
même gate C-NOT suivie d'un NOT sur le qubit 1. Cette dernière gate NOT n'affecte pas le qubit zéro. Donc quand la fonction
est équilibrée, nous mesurerons le qubit 0 dans l'état un à la fin du circuit. Maintenant si tu n'as pas suivi tout
cela, c'est correct. Je te suggère de le parcourir toi-même pour voir comment cela fonctionne. Le point principal ici est ce qui s'est
passé quand nous avons appliqué le C-NOT pour les deux fonctions équilibrées. Le qubit 0 n'était utilisé que comme qubit de contrôle pour changer
l'état du qubit 1. Intuitivement, tu pourrais penser que le qubit 0 resterait inchangé. Et pourtant, d'une façon ou d'une autre, nos
opérations sur le qubit un changent en réalité l'état du qubit zéro en changeant la phase relative entre les deux parties de
sa superposition. Ce phénomène est connu sous le nom de mécanisme de phase kickback et il est
très contre-intuitif comme beaucoup de phénomènes quantiques. D'une certaine façon, tu peux penser au mécanisme de phase kickback
comme ramer dans un bateau. L'acte de pousser l'eau vers l'arrière te propulse en réalité vers l'avant. Tout comme les opérations sur
le qubit 1 changent en réalité le qubit zéro. Maintenant nous pouvons exécuter l'algorithme de Deutsch sur
Qiskit. Ici nous pouvons sélectionner quelle fonction mettre à l'intérieur de la boîte noire, que nous avons choisie d'être F3. Voici le
diagramme du circuit de l'algorithme et nous pouvons l'exécuter comme avant avec le sampler primitif. Nous allons régler le nombre de
samples à juste un et voir ce que nous mesurons. Dans ce cas, nous avons mesuré un.
Donc, nous savons que la fonction était équilibrée, ce qui est en effet ce que nous attendions puisque la boîte noire contenait la fonction f3. Donc, avec juste une seule
requête, nous avons pu différencier entre ces deux classes de fonctions.
Cela aurait nécessité deux requêtes à un algorithme classique pour le déterminer. Cela montre un avantage modeste de l'informatique
quantique sur l'informatique classique seule, mais ce n'est pas très impressionnant. Juste un contre deux. Mais l'algorithme de Deutsch
WEBVTT
est encore extrêmement important dans l'histoire de l'informatique quantique parce qu'il a fourni l'étincelle qui a incité d'autres
à réfléchir à des algorithmes quantiques plus grands et plus sophistiqués.
Cela inclut une extension multi-qubits de l'algorithme de Deutsch qui démontre un avantage quantique bien plus impressionnant.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'algorithme de Deutsch-Jozsa. Il résout un problème similaire, mais dans ce cas, la fonction de la boîte noire
que nous voulons apprendre prend n bits en entrée et produit un seul bit. Comme
avant, on nous promet que la fonction est soit constante, c'est-à-dire que le bit de sortie est toujours un ou toujours zéro,
quelle que soit la chaîne de bits d'entrée, soit équilibrée, ce qui signifie que la sortie est zéro pour
la moitié des chaînes de bits d'entrée et un pour l'autre moitié. Il existe bien sûr d'autres
fonctions qui prennent n bits vers un seul bit qui ne sont ni constantes ni équilibrées. Mais dans ce problème, on nous
promet qu'aucune de ces fonctions n'est à l'intérieur de la boîte noire. Celle dans la boîte est garantie d'être soit constante
soit équilibrée. Le circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa ressemble à l'algorithme de Deutsch, mais avec plus de qubits. Nous avons ici une
implémentation de l'algorithme de Deutsch-Jozsa pour apprendre une fonction à trois bits. Cette fois nous avons trois qubits
pour l'état d'entrée plutôt qu'un seul. Et puis nous avons ce dernier qubit pour l'état de sortie. Comme avant, là aussi
nous préparons tous les qubits d'entrée dans l'état 0 + 1 et le qubit de sortie
dans l'état 0 moins 1. Bien que les mathématiques soient un peu plus compliquées à suivre, le principe
reste le même. Si la fonction est constante, elle ne dépendra pas du tout des trois qubits du haut. Donc leurs états
se transformeront en retour à zéro après les seconds Hadamards et notre mesure donnera une chaîne à trois bits de tous
des zéros. Mais si la fonction est équilibrée alors quand nous mesurons les qubits après les Hadamards, le phase kickback
mécanisme fera qu'un ou plusieurs de ces bits seront à un. Ce n'est peut-être pas si facile à voir cette fois mais si tu travailles
à travers chaque étape toi-même tu verras bientôt que c'est forcément le cas. Une façon de vérifier cela est d'essayer de calculer la
probabilité de mesurer tous les zéros avec une fonction équilibrée. Tu devrais obtenir une probabilité de zéro. Exécutons l'
algorithme de Deutsch-Jozsa sur un ordinateur quantique avec Qiskit. L'étape la plus difficile est probablement de créer la fonction de Deutsch-Jozsa
qui sera notre boîte noire que nous interrogeons ici. Ce code produit une fonction de Deutsch-Jozsa aléatoire qui est
garantie d'être soit équilibrée soit constante. Ensuite nous créons notre circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa en y insérant notre boîte noire
ici. Là encore, nous exécutons le circuit avec le sampler et après avoir mesuré, nous regardons
les bits mesurés pour déterminer si la fonction était équilibrée ou constante.
S'ils sont tous à zéro, c'est constant. Mais s'il y a au moins un bit à un dans la chaîne, alors c'est équilibrée. Dans ce
cas, nous obtenons une chaîne de bits de 1 un un.
Donc, nous savons que la fonction était équilibrée. J'espère t'avoir donné ton premier aperçu de comment les algorithmes quantiques
peuvent tirer avantage de phénomènes quantiques intéressants et souvent subtils pour obtenir leur avantage sur les algorithmes
classiques. Tu as probablement aussi remarqué à quel point il peut être difficile de concevoir des algorithmes quantiques. Même le tout premier
a nécessité beaucoup de créativité pour obtenir juste un modeste avantage sur les méthodes classiques. Et depuis ce premier algorithme,
les physiciens et les informaticiens ont continué à trouver des moyens incroyablement ingénieux d'utiliser la mécanique quantique
à leur avantage, y compris de nouvelles extensions et applications de l'algorithme de Deutsch-Jozsa. Si tu veux
en savoir plus sur certaines d'entre elles, ainsi qu'essayer les algorithmes de Deutsch et Deutsch-Jozsa toi-même, rends-toi sur
le module lié dans la description pour commencer. Merci de regarder et à la prochaine fois.